I'm much more world worried about Google
I'm worried about Amazon I'm worried
about Microsoft I'm also worried about
Facebook but you know the guys who
independently sell AI and the people who
sell smart devices they're the ones you
really got to worry about right and why
is that well sit there let's think about
AI is the example okay so we've almost
every day there's a new story about an
AI with some bang some implicit bias
based so you look you get the situation
of the the facial recognition that
either doesn't recognize women which I
think was a Microsoft product or doesn't
recognize people of color which was the
Google product we're all Asian people
look the same I think was their major
problem and then you've got then you've
got the problem of of resume a is that
read resumes and because they're trained
with data from the real world they have
bias based on gender and based on race
and then you have the AI that's used for
mortgage applications and then again the
real world has redlining it has bias
based on religion race and other factors
you know in each neighborhood right and
the problem is there are economic forces
for whom those biases served a purpose
right and you know I think if you're
Google you kind of like having a
homogeneous employee base of white and
Asian males between 25 and 35 right and
so if you can sit there and say whoa
this AI is doing it in its value neutral
right it can sort of gets you off the
hook if everything it recommends is AI
and algorithms are the furthest from
neutral that's the point they be
inherent they inherit the biases people
create them all I'm saying is that we as
human beings tend to defer to Authority
we tend to defer to technology because
we think it's better and in the old
Silicon Valley philosophy the thing
that's caused all the harm with a lot of
these global apps is that we still ship
a product and then expect the people who
use it to find the bugs behind the flaws
and that was fine if you're making a
little PC Gamer you're
process word processor it's not at all
cool when your product affects the
outcome of civilizations or affects
people's lives and mental health and
with AI I believe we have to verify
safety efficacy and absence of bias as a
condition to putting it into the market
and these are things that should be
automated right this isn't like a
10-year trial for these things this is
something you should be able to automate
now we're not very good at doing it
today which tells me we shouldn't be
deploying these things at scale because
you're gonna lock in all kinds of really
bad behaviors I mean I'm still trying to
find is there a single AI in use today
that doesn't have some unacceptable bias
built into it yeah because it appears to
me as though that might be a feature not
a bug for at least some people in that
value chain we're creating a digital
caste system that is executed by AI and
well and if you think that we're
accompanying it with a gig economy
that's creating a whole new generation
of serfs
right and so I'm looking at this and
going I want to get back to the
fundamentals and just say look I believe
that AI should be that the technology
penicillin of the 21st century done
right and I believe that we are good
enough in the valley to not only get
this right but to make it fantastic in
fact I believe that what we're really
setting up is the greatest business
opportunity in the history of technology
that the problems I'm describing each
one of them is a business opportunity
yeah and yet a predict when somebody is
going to have a neurological disease and
through their mouse and what other
searches they're doing but it has to be
private to that right but it to
interfere and and maybe help them would
be noble and amazing it would be as long
as they are the customer Yeah right I
mean part of the problem a drug company
part of the problem here is that all of
these things are being done you know
they say that in advertising you're not
the customer you're the product yeah
well in this world you're not even the
product you're the fuel and that is an
unacceptable thing that is wrong and I
believe it's because we're hyper
centralized you know we've allowed the
all industries in America this is by the
way this is not just a tech problem the
banking industry has these problems
energy industry has these problems you
know the tech industry is really in many
ways just doing
same thing that companies all over do if
we are the most effective but I believe
that that it's really a symbol that
we've been following the same basic
strategy economically for too long and
it's time to regress to the mean we need
more people to participate in the in the
up side and that's I mean that's the
political conversation we should be
having in 2020 we should be getting back
to technology fulfilling the Steve Jobs
vision of bicycles for the mind of
empowering us right instead of taking
away the things you know taking away our
jobs taking away what we think taking
away what we like right we don't want to
delegate those things to a is what we'd
really rather do is have the AI tell us
hang on just a sec you need to go to the
doctor mmm right and those kinds of
things are worth a lot of money right
and you know protecting people from
invasions of privacy is itself a
business opportunity right and you know
why is the cloud a set of giant you know
casks into which data gets dumped why
isn't it an infinite series of virtual
virtual clouds where where n is the
number of customers people wildly more
strong you're a wildly more prime why do
you have to take device why do you want
to process things in the cloud why not
just press that on the device we have
tons of processing on these smart phones
yeah right and we're about to go to to
5g where you're gonna have processing
all over the place it's insane to move
stuff into the cloud on that basis yeah
yeah I mean to be moving video unless
you want to own all the data sorry
that's my point yeah and that's what we
need to have some some government
intervention